und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka guten abend
bund und länder beraten heute über eine
ganze reihe von ukraine krieg über
energiesicherheit bis corona pandemie
und bei letzteren ist eines zumindest
sicher wenn im herbst eine neue welle
über das land schwappt wird niemand
sagen können hoch das kommt jetzt aber
überraschend
der überraschungseffekt könnte er in der
frage liegen wann beginnt der herbst
allzu kalendarisch sollte man das wohl
besser nicht verstehen durch portugal
zieht gerade ja eine ordentliche sommer
welle dank neuer omikron variante der
bundesgesundheitsminister mit dem ich
darüber vorhin gesprochen habe will das
gegebenenfalls neue schutzmaßnahmen
ergriffen werden können dafür müsste er
aber erstmal die fdp überzeugen aus
berlin britta spiekermann
karl lauterbach bereitet sich vor auf
seine rede im bundestag und auch auf den
herbst und eine möglicherweise neue
corona welle der widerstand gegen viele
maßnahmen sitzt allerdings in der
eigenen ampel regierung wir dürfen nicht
erneut
unvorbereitet wie im letzten herbst in
die krise gehen wir müssen gut
vorbereitet sagt impfkonzept test
strategien lauterbach kündigt an viele
absichten beschlossen ist nichts er
müsse jetzt mit den ländern reden große
krisen ganz große runde die spitzen der
länder und der ministerien und
bundeskanzler chance die krieg in der
ukraine energieversorgung und eben
corona misstöne im vorfeld wir haben
eine geschichte hinter uns zumindest das
letzte halbe jahr in dem die
bundesregierung sehr klar gesagt hat
dass sie das alles alleine tun will und
jetzt muss sie sagen wie es im herbst
weitergehen soll wie es im herbst
weitergehen soll der bund soll es
richten sagen die unionsgeführten länder
am abend pressekonferenz stolz lobt die
freundschaftliche zusammenkunft in
präsenz der sommer habe die lage
verbessert diese können sich im herbst
ändern die impfstoffe die dazu gebraucht
werden um diejenigen die sich impfen
lassen wollen zu unterstützen die alle
geschafft und sind bereits geschafft ein
punkt will ich nochmal vorherigen aus
dem gemeinsamen beschluss es soll keine
erneuten flächendeckenden schließungen
von schulen und
kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen geben die
pandemie ist nicht vorbei niemand will
zurück zu einem hin und her von londons
und lockerungen jetzt wegen ist wichtig
dass wir heute die richtigen weichen
gestellt haben uns weiter auch über den
sommer um das thema zu kümmern
schulen und kitas sollen bei einer
möglichen neuen welle also nicht mehr
generell schließen ansonsten bleibt
vieles offen 2g 3g abstand halten masken
pflicht die liberalen wollen
weitestgehend weg von staatlichen
maßnahmen
wir sind in deutschland den europäischen
weg gegangen und ich sage mal nicht den
chinesischen weg und das muss auch für
den herbst gelten wir sollten auf eigene
verantwortung setzen und gleichzeitig
dafür sorgen dass die datengrundlage
besser ist und dass es im dritten jahr
der pandemie keine ausreichende
datenlage gibt bestreitet dem
politischen betrieb kaum noch jemand
trotzdem sollen jetzt irgendwie der
herbst vorbereitet werden intensiv
mediziner warnen schon jetzt es werden
uns betten fehlen und ich habe darauf
muss man sich vorbereiten
wir haben nicht nur meckern wir haben
nicht nur neue variante sondern wir
haben auch eine dramatisch sich
verschärfende situation bei den
pflegenden im gesundheitssystem ob
corona nach einem entspannten sommer mit
wucht zurückkehrt weiß niemand am 23
september läuft das
infektionsschutzgesetz aus es bleiben
viele drängende fragen auf wiedervorlage
und der bundesgesundheitsminister ist
uns zugeschaltet guten abend herr
lauterbach
slomka sie gehören ja auch zu denen die
vor dem herbst warnen man fragt sich so
ein bisschen wann beginnt dieser herbst
also wenn wir nach portugal sehen die
haben jetzt schon eine ordentliche
sommer welle das ist richtig aber in
portugal ist auch die immunität etwas
schneller zurückgegangen weil man dort
früher geimpft hat wir werden also
später ähnliche probleme möglicherweise
bekommen portugal kämpft mit der
sogenannten omikron b a 5 variante die
sich auch in deutschland jetzt schon
verbreitet werden es schon zu fünf
prozent das heißt das könnte durchaus im
herbst die variante sein mit der wir
kämpfen müssen ist die gefährlicher als
die alte omikron variante man verliert
so ein bisschen den überblick manchmal
über die varianten und sie ist auf jeden
fall ansteckender und gefährlicher als
die ursprüngliche omikron variante baa1
das glaube ich kann man schon sagen aber
ob sie gefährlicher ist als die mit der
wir jetzt zu tun haben wir zwei das
wissen wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
nicht das ist auf jeden fall eine
variante die man nicht haben möchte und
wo wir gut vorbereitet sein müssen diese
vorbereitung geht es ja sie haben da
einige förderung oder vorschläge wie die
eindämmung dann wieder im herbst
passieren konnte aber es sieht nicht so
aus als würde ihr koalitionspartner die
fdp damit machen na ja wir sind in
verhandlungen das wird gut klappen was
da bin ich zuversichtlich
jeder will ja dass wir im herbst gut
vorbereitet sind und wir haben da
einiges auch schon gemeinsam geschafft
wir haben zb impfstoffe bestellt die für
ganz unterschiedliche varianten wirken
wir also haben die impfzentren schön
weiter finanziert wir machen konzepte
also für das infektionsschutzgesetz sie
werden später auch mit den ländern
besprechen das haben wir heute
beschlossen somit also die vorbereitung
läuft auch hochtouren und wird gut sein
also was die fdp macht ist quasi ihnen
den ball zu werfen und zu sagen ja also
solange wir jetzt keine wirkliche
evaluierung also bewertung die wirksam
welche maßnahmen sind haben so lange
wollen wir auch keine neuen massnahmen
beschliessen wieder irgendwer
sachverständigenausschuss der für die
evaluierung dieser maßnahmen zuständig
ist also nee bis sommer in diesem jahr
dass das wird auf keinen fall geben
sprich dabei sich dann die katze doch
irgendwie in den schwanz wir bereiten
einige dinge jetzt schon vor zum
beispiel beschaffung von impfstoffen wir
überlegen uns was die richtige test
strategie ist das muss ja auch
beschlossen werden überhaupt bevor das
infektionsschutzgesetz
evaluiert es wo die fdp also wert darauf
legt ist dass wir diese kommission
abwarten
am 30.06 liegt das gremium das gutachten
ja vor für die reform des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und das kann
ich auch gut verstehen da warten wir
dann darauf dass es kein problem aber es
gibt darüber hinaus zahlreiche dinge die
jetzt schon vorbereitet werden müssen
und diese vorbereitung finden auch schon
statt
aber es gibt ja der fdp auch stimmen die
bezweifeln aber jetzt zum beispiel
masken überhaupt was bringen und darum
masken pflicht in innenräumen das ist ja
so etwas was sie sich da im herbst dann
wieder vorstellen das möchte man doch
lieber zumindestens nicht voreilig
beschließen
voreilige beschlüsse gibt es nicht es
geht ja auch nur darum dass wir die
möglichkeit beschließen und das wird
aber jetzt mit der fdp und auch mit
anderen für das diskutiert die
studienlage ist ganz klar also dass
masken wirksam sind dass es also belegt
jetzt ist erst wieder eine große studie
mit über 20 millionen teilnehmern
veröffentlicht worden wo der wert der
masken noch einmal belegt werden konnte
das gegenteil wir auch eine überraschung
gewesen ich glaube dass sie darüber
einkommen sie sprachen eben die
impfstoffe an wird es denn impfstoffe
für diese neuen varianten geben bisher
gibt es ja noch nicht mal einen omikron
im stoff man läuft daher eigentlich
immer so ein bisschen den büros
hinterher in der tat verzögert sich die
entwicklung neuer impfstoffe im moment
etwas weil die hersteller dann doch mehr
probleme haben also die daten zu
generieren
die notwendig sind wir rechnen damit in
den nächsten wochen aber wir sind auf
jeden fall bei mehreren herstellern sind
wir gebucht so dass ich sicher bin dass
wir einen guten impfstoff allen anbieten
können und nochmal auf das
infektionsschutzgesetz das läuft dann
dreiundzwanzigster september aussagen
sie hier und heute da wird auf jeden
fall ein ersatz für geben das ist auch
die angst der länder dass es dann gar
nichts mehr gibt nein das ist ganz klar
darauf haben wir uns heute auch noch mal
geeinigt wir machen vorschläge die
bundesregierung macht vorschläge das
wird dann mit den ländern diskutiert und
auf der grundlage wird das
infektionsschutzgesetz sondern neu
geregelt so dass wir auf jeden fall über
den 23 09 hinweg an
infektionsschutzgesetz haben was uns die
vorberatung gibt die wir brauchen sagt
der bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
danken für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
einheitliche linie zu finden immer
schwer erst recht in der internationalen
politik wir dachten die eu-länder sie
hätten jetzt endlich ihr sechstes
sanktionspaket gegen russland fertig
geschnürt schon kam ungarn zaubern
wieder um die ecke und meldete neue
widerstände an und so wird der patriarch
der russisch orthodoxen kirche kirill
nun doch nicht auf die sanktionsliste
gesetzt das ist übrigens der
kirchenführer der auf fotos schon mal
seine luxus uhr vom handgelenk
reduzieren lässt und seine predigten für
lupenreine putin propaganda nutzt der
wahl gehen in der ukraine die kämpfe
weiter beide seiten liefern sich schwere
gefechte christiane hofmann berichtet
ein papier modell zeigt wie die schule
in haag ybbs norden wohl einmal aussah
jetzt liegt sie in trümmern zwar sind
die russen schon vor wochen aus der
region rund um die zweitgrößte
ukrainische stadt abgezogen doch ruhe
ist nicht eingekehrt eine frau sei ums
leben gekommen erzählen sie
hier haben einige leute nachts
geschlafen tagsüber waren sie zu hause
aber nachts habe sie hier in der schule
schutz gesucht
schwer umkämpft ist weiter der donbass
besonders die stadt jever roten jetzt
laut britischen geheimdienst haben die
russen die stadt größtenteils
eingenommen an tag 99 des krieges steht
severin jetzt kurz vor dem fall die
zwillingsstadt lässig wird noch gehalten
fällt auch sie hätten die russen die
region luhansk unter vollständiger
kontrolle bei einer video schalte mit
dem parlament von luxemburg beschreibt
der ukrainische präsident die lage
ungefähr 20 prozent unseres territoriums
sind unter kontrolle der besatzer es ist
mehr als das territorium der benelux
staaten zusammen
das ist die einzige noch offene straße
nach serotonins kein französisches
kamerateam konnte diese bilder drehen
sie treffen auf krankenwagen und
ausgebrannte fahrzeuge jeden tag seit
die straße unter beschuss sagt der
gewinne von lohans evakuierungen von
zivilisten de facto unmöglich geworden
die meisten einwohner seien geflohen
zurück bleiben nur die ganz armen und
alten die nicht mehr weg können sie
erwarten das schlimmste
johannes hahn ist für uns in der ukraine
derzeit in der hafenstadt und deshalb
johannes was hast du dort von der
ukrainischen seite wie wird das aktuelle
kriegsgeschehen dort eingeschätzt und
welche entwicklung erwartet man da in
nächster zeit
also wir sind heute morgen um 6 uhr
ungefähr von einem schweren luft damen
aus den betten gerissen worden beim
explosionen gehört ob und was getroffen
wurde das wissen wir bis heute abend
nicht die nachbarstadt nikolaev eine
großstadt wurde von russischen raketen
und russische angetroffen wir sind heute
durch gefahren und haben da menschen
gesehen die an tanklastern um wasser
anstehen und das text nicht so ziemlich
genau mit dem was der ukrainische
generalstab warnt wovor er warnt ganzen
tages schon dass nämlich die russischen
streitkräfte dazu übergehen die
kritische infrastruktur die zivile
kritische infrastruktur und die
militärische komplett zerstören zu
wollen also diese raketen angriffe
zielen alle in diese richtung und 1
vielleicht noch wir waren heute bei
einer brigade die hier im süden dabei
ist die russischen truppen
zurückzudrängen hat man sehr genau
hingehört was der bundeskanzler gestern
versprochen hat nämlich die lieferung
von luftabwehrsysteme und raketenwerfern
dass er genau das was man brauche und
man hat er sehr sehr positiv aufgenommen
aber man hat uns auch gesagt das bett
kommt muss er heute als morgen kommt das
könnte morgen schon zu spät sein
dankeschön johannes
zu krieg und sanktionen gibt es nach dem
heute-journal update noch ein gespräch
mit manfred weber dem vorsitzenden der
fdp im europäischen parlament und zu den
folgen dieses krieges gehört ja auch
dass sich einige europäische länder
sicherheitspolitisch neu aufstellen dazu
passt eine erste nachricht in dänemark
gibt seine langjährige außenseiterrolle
in der verteidigungs- und
sicherheitspolitik der eu auf in einer
volksabstimmung haben sich knapp 67
prozent der däninnen und dänen für eine
beteiligung an der europäischen
verteidigung zusammenarbeit
ausgesprochen und damit auch für die
unterstützung militärischer missionen
der ebene der dänische außenminister
kussa erklärte zusammenhalt in europa
sei die beste antwort auf die
gegenwärtige situation
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
hat polen aufgefordert vereinbarte
justiz reformen umzusetzen damit nach
langem streit zugesagte eu hilfsgelder
von 24 milliarden euro ausgezahlt werden
können in warschau erklärte sie man sei
in bezug auf die rechtsstaatlichkeit in
polen noch nicht am ende des weges erst
müsse polen die unabhängigkeit der
justiz gewährleisten dann erfolge die
auszahlung der gelder
der bundestag wird den bundeswehreinsatz
in afghanistan mit einem
untersuchungsausschuss und einer enquete
kommission aufarbeiten
darauf haben sich die fraktionen der
ampel koalition und der union
verständigt beide gremien sollen noch
vor der sommerpause gebildet werden ziel
sind lehren für das künftige
militärische und zivile internationale
engagement deutschlands
erneut erschüttert ein amoklauf die usa
knapp eine woche nach dem massaker in
einer grundschule in texas hat im us
bundesstaat oklahoma ein bewaffneter
eine klinik gestürmt vier menschen
erschossen und anschließend sich selbst
nach polizeiangaben hatte der 45-jährige
auf einen arzt gezielt den er für
schmerzen nach einer operation
verantwortlich machte nach den jüngsten
schusswaffen angriffen arbeitet der us
senat an einer leichten verschärfung des
waffenrechts
dass er mal an krieg die umstellung auf
erneuerbare energien vorantreiben würde
hätte man sich auch nicht ausgemalt
zugleich macht dass der krieg im moment
aber ja erstmal auch schwieriger dem
klima und umweltschutz den stellenwert
einzuräumen den wissenschaftler dringend
einfordern und das tun sie bekanntlich
schon lange die erste un umweltkonferenz
fand vor 50 jahren stark den stock
kommen das war quasi die geburtsstunde
einer globalen umweltpolitik
daran erinnert der aktuelle umweltgipfel
dort zu unter dem titel stockholm +50
christian decker erinnert an 50 jahre
mit vielen vergebenen chancen aber auch
fortschritten
anfang der 70er jahre die luft voller
schadstoffe in den flüssen kann man
nicht mehr schwimmen
der aufschwung von industrie und
wirtschaft hat seine spuren hinterlassen
in weiten teilen der welt der eindruck
so kann es nicht weitergehen
1972 zum ersten mal in der
menschheitsgeschichte wird über globale
umweltprobleme diskutiert vertreterinnen
und vertreter aus 122 ländern treffen
sich in stockholm der grundstein für die
internationale umwelt- und klimapolitik
er jochen flasbarth war da zwar noch
nicht dabei dafür aber auch vielen der
folgenden konferenzen
aber dass in stockholm ein positiver
prozess gestartet worden ist jedenfalls
mag man sich den zustand dieser welt
nicht vorstellen müssen ohne die
gemeinsamen anstrengungen im
umweltschutz und sind daraus themen
entstanden die man damals noch nicht
genau gesehen hat zum beispiel den
klimaschutz nun in stockholm die
jubiläumsfeier aber eigentlich geht es
um die konferenz die ungelösten probleme
denn dies sind heute 50 jahre später
nicht weniger geworden die
bundesumweltministerin mit einer klaren
erwartung die drei großen ökologischen
krisen klimakrise arten aussterben und
verschmutzung dass klar wird dass wir
diese drei großen krisen nur gemeinsam
lösen können dass wir die eine nicht
gegen die andere ausspielen dürfen und
dass wir keine zeit mehr zu verlieren
haben um sie alle drei gleichzeitig
anzugehen
stockholm war der startpunkt vieler
umwelt und klimaschutz konferenzen die
seit 1995 mit ausnahme von 2020 wie in
corona jedes jahr stattgefunden haben
beschlossen wurde viel umgesetzt
mitunter wenig
die plastik produktion ist seit 1972 von
38 millionen tonnen auf 367 millionen im
jahr 2020 gestiegen ein zuwachs von 866
die folge große müllprobleme vor allem
im meer
rund eine million tier und pflanzenarten
könnten in wenigen jahrzehnten
aussterben warnt der welt biodiversitäts
rat
seit stockholm 1972 ist die temperatur
weltweit um etwa 0,8 vier grad gestiegen
in den letzten jahrzehnten deutlich
beschleunigt das 1,5 grad ziel des
pariser abkommens überhaupt noch zu
erreichen ist schon heute in gefahr vor
allem stellt man bei diesem gipfel hier
fest dass man nicht so weitermachen kann
wie bisher 56 jahre klima gibt für 50
jahre leere versprechen 50 jahre
klimazerstörung in diesen 50 jahren ist
wurde 90 prozent der
menschlich gemachten erhitzung des
planeten produziert nach einem halben
jahrhundert konferenzen muss das tempo
endlich anziehen sehr viel zeit zum
handeln bleibt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
und jetzt nochmal gundula mit weiteren
meldungen des tages das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat vorgaben
zum wohneigentum von hartz 4 beziehen
für rechtens erklärt demnach bekommt
auch weiterhin diese staatliche leistung
nur wer über ein begrenztes vermögen
verfügt geklagt hatte ein ehepaar das
nach dem auszug aller sechs kinder
allein im selbst erbauten haus lebt dem
auf hartz iv angewiesenen ehepaar sei
der verkauf des hauses zumutbar
urteilten die karlsruher richter
durch pandemie inflation und steigende
lebenshaltungskosten geraten immer mehr
menschen in finanzielle not darauf haben
die
schuldnerberatungsstellen in deutschland
heute aufmerksam gemacht dazu kommt das
problem schon hohe mieten stefanie berit
und möglicher weiterer erhöhungen wie
reagieren die wohnungskonzern auf die
aktuelle kritik die vorstände der
wohnung der tochter deutsche wohnen
waren heute auf der aktionärsversammlung
in berlin zumindest sichtlich bemüht die
wogen wieder zu glätten und versicherten
mieter müssten sich keine sorgen machen
in folge von mietern passungen ihre
miete nicht mehr zahlen zu können für
wirbel und kritik gesorgt hatte ein
vorstoß von bono via schiff holz buch
der generell deutliche mieterhöhungen
fordert wenn die inflation dauerhaft bei
vier prozent liegt müssen auch die
mieten künftig jährlich dementsprechend
ansteigen mieterverbände verweisen
dagegen auf klare gesetzliche hürden im
rahmen von vergleichsmieten und
mietspiegel doch eines steht fest auch
jenseits mögliche erhöhungen müssen sich
mieter derzeit warm anziehen allein für
mietnebenkosten könnten in diesem jahr
bis zu zwei monatsmieten anfallen
andererseits kommen auch auf vermieter
höhere ausgaben zu wenn es etwa um
klimafreundliche sanierungen geht da
möchte man auch nicht in der haut manche
eigentümer stecken denn die renditen bei
wohnungs vermietungen sind oftmals weit
weniger üppig als vermutet bei einem
wohnungskonzern vivo novia allerdings
der erst kürzlich einen jahresüberschuss
von über zweieinhalb milliarden euro
verkündet hat die forderung nach
mieterhöhungen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
aber durchaus einen faden beigeschmack
vielen dank stefanie in der fabrik an
zum sport die handballer des sc
magdeburg haben am abend den ersten
meistertitel seit 21 jahren vorzeitig
perfekt gemacht großer jubel drei
spieltage vor saisonende magdeburg lag
mit einem polster von sechs punkten vor
verfolger thw kiel und lieferte sich am
abend zunächst ein enges spiel gegen die
hbw balingen weilstetten am ende der
glückliche sieg 31 zu 26
fußball-bundesligist hertha bsc hat
einen neuen trainer den vierten
innerhalb von zwölf monaten sandro
schwarz folgt auf felix magath der 43
jährige kommt vom russischen
erstligisten dynamo moskau
der mannschaft habe er sich auch nach
kriegsbeginn verpflichtet gefühlt in
berlin soll schwarz den neustart der
hertha gestalten nachdem gerade knapp
gesicherten klassenerhalt
bundespräsident steinmeier hat ein
versprechen eingelöst in mainz hat er
sich über die situation von
hilfsbedürftigen und obdachlosen
informiert bei einem besuch des vereins
armut und gesundheit dem projekt von
sozialmediziner gerhard trabert der bei
der bundespräsidentenwahl gegen
steinmeier kandidiert hatte trabert
mache auf lücken im system aufmerksam
würdigte steinmeier dessen engagement
und helfen tatkräftig
das vereinigte königreich feiert seine
königin unglaubliche 70 jahre sitzt sie
ja nun auf dem thron allein wenn man
überlegt was wem diese 96 jahre alte
regentin alles hat kommen und gehen
sehen als sie 1952 den thronsaal im
buckingham palace erstmals als königin
betrat war sie eine junge frau der
premierminister hieß noch winston
churchill und das britische empire das
gab es auch noch war aber damals schon
stark geschrumpft zur zeit seiner
größten ausdehnung noch wenige jahre vor
der geburt der queen nahm das empire
fast 25 prozent der landmasse unseres
gesamten planeten ein
davon ist heute nicht mehr viel übrig
und so feiern die briten in diesen tagen
schon auch ein gutes stück weit den
glanz eines vergangenen zeitalters und
blicken zugleich in eine ungewisse
zukunft
diana zimmermann berichtet
das reich markt geschrumpft sein an den
massen die nach london strömten aber
konnte man das heute nicht ablesen
zigtausende harten aus um einen blick
auf die kutschen der royals zu erhaschen
auf die prachtvolle militär parade und
später auf die queen selbst mit typische
handbewegung
party hunger nach den corona jahren und
ein extra feiertag für 70 thronjubiläum
oben die stimmung
ein londoner und hier um der queen eine
unterstützung zu zeigen und einheit
durch diversität zu feiern
eine solche feier wird ist nicht mehr
geben unsere queen ist die wunderbarste
königin das weiß jeder
nostalgie ist auch dabei schließlich war
die queen für die allermeisten schon
immer da beruhigt und ermutigt wenn die
welt unerträglich schrill erscheint was
also passiert wenn auch sie eines tages
gehen muss
er wird dann die frage sein wir haben
kein empire mehr wir sind ein kleines
land nicht mal mehr teil der eu aber
manche unserer politiker glauben immer
noch dass wir diese großartig souveräne
nation sind aber sind wir dass
eine frage so kritiker der monarchie die
das land sich längst hätte stellen
müssen die ihnen gilt die queen weniger
als trost denn als etwas das die briten
zurückhält auf dem weg nach vorn
das interessante an der männer hier ist
sie stellt extreme ungleichheit als
etwas normales da und sagt uns dass wir
dort hinein geboren ist einfach glück
hatte und wir das feiern sollten
gefeiert wird auch dass die 96-jährige
der fixpunkt in einer welt ist die sich
radikal verändert hat das jubiläumsjahr
ist ein krisenjahr wirtschaftlich
steuert großbritannien auf einer
rezession zu politisch hat spätestens
der praxis gezeigt wie uneinig das
vereinigte königreich ist der aktuelle
elisabeth vierzehnter premier ist in
fast allen punkten das genaue gegenteil
ihrer majestät was die queen zu boris
johnstons partie gate und sonstigem
gebaren denken mag kann man ahnen wenn
schon kein mensch wie jeder andere so
ist es ihr doch gelungen ein besonders
anständiger zu sein
sie steht für diese altmodische idee von
pflichtbewusstsein von dienst und ich
glaube dass es doch einen angeborenen
respekt dafür empfinden auch wenn die
jüngeren leute das als altes zeug aus
dem neunzehnten jahrhundert abtun
was selbst ihr nicht gelungen ist ist
das ansehen der königlichen familie
unbeschadet zu halten standen vor zehn
jahren noch 75 prozent der briten hinter
der monarchie sind es heute nur noch 62
prozent aber die vielen die die kleine
alte dame heute in london bejubelten
machten überdeutlich dass sie ihre queen
für unerlässlich halten
ja so schön wurde sie gefeiert aber das
war auch sehr anstrengend für die 96
jährige queen und beim dankgottesdienst
morgen in der st paul's cathedral wird
sie nicht dabei sein ist es jetzt am
abend aus dem buckingham palace
und hier geht es jetzt gleich weiter bei
maybrit illner zu ihren gästen gehören
heute unter anderem robert habeck kevin
kühnert und unsere ukraine reporterin
katrin eigendorf und
um 0.25 meldet sich nach einem jahr mit
unserem heute-journal update auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das war für viele von ihnen
sicherlich ein angenehmer tag und das
lag an der geringen luftfeuchte heute
mittag lag sie hier in einem breiten
streifen vom oberpfälzer wald bis zum
oberrhein nur so bei 30 bis 50 prozent
das ist noch nicht die dampfzüge
gewitter luft die wir in den nächsten
tagen erwarten und die wird angetrieben
von diesen kleinen gewittertief über
südfrankreich und das wiederum wird
gesteuert von dem tief vor portugal und
so kommt die gewitter luft direkt zu uns
die hochs weichen auseinander und machen
platz für diese gewitter duft erste
kleinere gewitter kann es auch heute
nacht schulen in baden württemberg geben
häufig aber ist es noch klar und da wird
es wieder kalt dann sinken die
temperaturen auf vier oder drei grad
dann droht sogar noch einmal bodenfrost
milder bleibt die nacht zum beispiel auf
norderney oder auch im süden und
südwesten bei 14 bis 10 grad und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen direkt an
der nordsee nur so bei 17 grad 29 grad
werden es dagegen im rhein main gebiet
der vormittag beginnt erstmal mit viel
sonne in süddeutschland kann es etwas
stärker bewölkt sein da kann es auch
noch mal regnen aus der nacht draußen
dann beginnt es von südwesten zu quellen
dann ziehen die kräftigen schauer und
gewitter auf von frankreich her richtung
saarland und rheinland pfalz und aus den
alpen heraus nach baden württemberg und
bayern es drohen unwetter mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen am samstag
ziehen die gewitter in abgeschwächter
form ab die nächsten unwetter drohen
dann am pfingstsonntag und die erreichen
den osten dann am pfingstmontag in
abgeschwächter form guten abend